[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 7 mars toute la France sera bloqué
contre la réforme des retraites et parce
que cette réforme nous concerne nous
aussi les jeunes on s'attend à ce que
tous les lycées et toutes les
universités soient bloquées contre la
réforme des retraites c'est pourquoi on
lance le hashtag blocus challenge postez
vos plus belles photos de blocus de
lycée et d'université parmi ces photos
on en tire à une sorte et l'équipe de
bloqueurs sera invité à visiter
l'Assemblée nationale avec nous donc on
se retrouve le mardi 7 mars pour mettre
le pays à l'arrêt et participer au
blocus challenge on se retrouve mardi
pour faire reculer ma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]